when a presidential candidate drops out
of the race what happens to all that
super PAC money independently raised to
get him elected well it doesn't go to
the candidate since super PACs are
independent groups where it does go is
up to whoever runs the super PAC
sometimes super PACs stay open and
support a different candidate or cause
if the super PAC is closing for good the
leftover cash can pay for winding down
expenses it can also go to a charity or
other nonprofit but donors probably want
a chunk of their money back super PACs
usually obliged but they're not required
to if he's feeling shady the guy running
the super PAC could funnel the money
toward himself or his business it's not
illegal giving all that money directly
to a federal candidates campaign though
that's never allowed but some states do
allow unlimited pac donations to state
campaigns like governor's races
democracy
you